Spiritualität,
buddhistische Traditionen seiner Vorväter –
das ist dem Tibeter Tenzin wichtig,
auch in der Schweiz.
2013 floh er hierher aus seiner Heimat,
gründete eine Familie.
Ich möchte hier in der Schweiz bleiben
und ein …
als Pflegeassistent arbeiten
und für meine Familie arbeiten und ja,
ein normales Leben leben.
In diesem Dorf bleiben,
sich eine neue Existenz aufbauen:
Davon träumt Tenzin.
Seinen richtigen Namen haben wir verändert.
Auch seine Frau floh in die Alpenrepublik.
Sie haben alle Brücken
in die alte Heimat abgebrochen,
rufen niemand an. Aus Angst.
Ich habe keinen Kontakt mit meiner Familie,
weil ich ihnen keine Probleme machen will.
Meine Familie wusste auch nicht,
dass ich zwei Kinder habe.
Das ist sehr traurig für mich
und habe ich [ich habe] auch sehr Heimweh.
An eine Rückkehr nach
Tibet ist nicht zu denken.
Drei Asylanträge haben
die Schweizer Behörden abgelehnt,
weil sie glauben, dass Tenzin über ein
sicheres Drittland hierherkam.
Ohne Papiere dürfen sie aber nicht arbeiten,
obwohl er ein Praktikum
als Altenpfleger gemacht hat.
Bei Behördengängen helfen Freunde,
die sie in der Schweiz gefunden haben.
Wir versuchen dann
von den Tibet-Organisationen her
sie zu unterstützen, ihnen zu helfen,
zum Beispiel mit dem „Paten-Netz“,
um ihnen den Alltag
etwas leichter zu machen.
Trost und Stille fürs Gebet.
Viele Tibeter finden es hier:
In einem buddhistischen Kloster
eine Autostunde nördlich von Zürich.
Auch Tenzin liebt diesen Ort.
Er erinnert ihn an seine Jugend.
Die habe er in einem Kloster verbracht.
Daran denkt er gerne zurück.
Alles schön.
Früh morgens aufstehen
und Betten machen, Frühstück
und mit Freunden spielen.
Das unbeschwerte Leben endete,
als chinesische Sicherheitskräfte
die Mönche drangsalierten.
Sie versuchten, sich dagegen zu wehren –
vergebens.
Jeden Tag stören sie uns
und unterdrücken sie uns
und unsere Freiheit.
Dagegen habe ich also Plakate geklebt
und Proteste gemacht.
Freunde sollen ihn gewarnt haben:
Die Polizei sei auf der Suche nach ihm.
Tenzin floh in die Schweiz.
Der Abt des Klosters:
Er kennt viele ähnliche Schicksale.
Im Grunde gibt es keine
Religionsfreiheit in China.
Wenn du die Regierung kritisierst,
werfen sie dich ins Gefängnis.
Darüber reden wollten wir auch mit jemandem
von der chinesischen Botschaft in Bern.
Doch unsere Interview-Anfragen
blieben unbeantwortet.
In die Schweiz geflohene Tibeter –
für die chinesischen Kommunisten
sind das Oppositionelle.
China setzt in den Beziehungen
zur Schweiz ganz auf den Ausbau
der ökonomischen Beziehungen.
Beide Länder verbindet seit 2013
ein Freihandelsabkommen.
Der Handel wächst kontinuierlich.
Wirtschaftsinteressen zu verfolgen
und dabei Demokratie
und Menschenrechte zu verteidigen –
ein Balanceakt für die Schweiz.
China tritt zunehmend autoritär auf,
setzt seine Interessen stärker durch
in der Wirtschaftspolitik,
in der Flüchtlingspolitik,
und darauf muss die Schweiz
auch reagieren und koordinierter vorgehen.
In die chinesische Botschaft musste auch
Tenzin vor einiger Zeit,
wollte sich bestätigen lassen,
dass er aus Tibet stammte.
Einmal,
ich bin zur chinesischen Botschaft gegangen,
einen Ausweis zu holen,
und sie haben angefangen
mich [mit mir] zu streiten
und ich fühlte mich bedroht.
Die Chinesen weigerten sich, ihm
entsprechende Papiere zu geben.
Nach wie vor fühlt er sich bedroht.
Schließlich haben ihm die Schweizer
Behörden bislang kein Asyl gewährt.
Wie es weitergehen soll –
er weiß es nicht.